welcome to this video this is a new part
of the middlegame strategy series
yeah let's have a look at the game it is
a complete game I don't want to start
with the key position right away but I
want to show how it proceeded to this
key position it's a game between the top
Spanish player Miguel Alaska's Cordoba
nowadays is not the number one in Spain
anymore he's mostly I think a chess
teacher having his chess school um and
on the black side we see Nigel short
long time to play off of England only
recently won the great open tournament a
great success winning the the PokerStars
Isle of Man tournament
let's see me what happened in this game
was played by the way in 1999 in
Pamplona Spain exactly on New Year's Eve
1999 so just one day before it was the
2000 on the calendar yeah let's see what
happened here we have a Queen's Gambit
classical and short is a long time
petitioner of the tatacoa variation only
recently featured to tell Tata cava game
and the chest giant serious it's a
little bit of a coincidence that we have
the same opening again here
yeah the topic covers one of them Tata
cover mckagan open or s key is one of
the most reliable lines that black can
play is black that black and played as
black yes that black can play in the
Queen's Gambit
it is both reliable but also still has
some dynamic potential because black
very often we get survivin and then it
will be hanging pawns in general the
pawn structures here are rather complex
hanging pawns isolated green porn
positions for both sides it's a very
rewarding opening
the yeah strategically focused player
but it will get dynamic and we see in
this game how this might unfold right
now played the move Bishop b2
yeah nowadays this move on the move rook
c1 and have played quite often the ideas
that what wide wants to do he wants to
ask black okay what is your next move
and the next move is Bishop d7
quite clearly if we have played b6 is
black to prepare the thing keto so we
should be seven is quite clear yeah and
now white starts an interesting
operation he takes on f6 and takes on d5
this is the whole idea of the waiting
move Bishop e2 he wants to play it in
this way
forcing a pawn to appear on d5 so this
diagonal is closed this is a difference
to some other setups for example if we
go back and we look at the traditional
mainline CD 5 and 95 should be seven
Queens 7 here this diagonal is open and
black will put a bishop there happily
all white takes when we get the same
pawn structure as in the lion played in
the game but here black has the
additional option to play Bishop e6 for
more of this line you can see the
recently released video in the chest
joint series between young Simon and FM
gala or if you want to look at an even
older example the six match game Fischer
Spassky the difference here is that
after this waiting move we have the same
structure but the bishop is looking at
its d5 pawn so we have an interesting
struggle black has the bishop pair and
he has both bishops on the long
diagonals here and here but both bishops
look at pawns the d4 pawn is securely
protected by e3 and he's looking at its
own pawns and the whole game here
has one theme what should black do to
try to activate his bishops white now
castles I don't want to do a super
detailed theoretical overview here white
also can play a before here by the way
it's in a different idea trying to
prevent or make it more difficult to
play c5 up like but okay castles is
perfectly okay short now place the move
Queen e7 which is definitely okay and it
prepares to play and we see this now
Rock the eight very interesting Black
has transferred his rook now to cover d5
why does attacking it twice and black is
protecting it twice as well so it is a
secure point on d5 white now played the
move rook F to d1 interesting what is
white doing here with this rooks this is
a very important question to answer to
be honest I don't like rook F t1 that
much but it might be also a matter of
taste
why on the default isn't this rook
looking at its own pawn right it is this
point but it is positioned on the
default to make it more difficult for
black to play the C file c5 attacking at
the center would be a very normal move
and inform break to make sure that they
have six bishops got something to do
attacking the D form pawn however with
the rook now on the one we see the idea
white can capture and now the rook is
putting this pressure on the pawn after
recapture here black has just blundered
to the central point so the rook on the
D file is placed there to hinder the c5
advance however I personally would
prefer to play the a rook to d1 why is
that that idea is the same as with rook
f t1 we put this in direct pressure on
d5 so that it is
more difficult for black to play c5 but
with rook a to d1 we keep one option
open and this is to play rook fe1 and
then later prepare the e4 break this is
an interesting plan the reason is that
the rook only one is opposed to the
Queen on e7 the Queen on e7 in general
has a quite good post there but it might
be tricky if white gets in this break
rupee one Bishop d3 and then if all this
is I think a plan that I probably would
prefer white in Aeschylus move with rook
FD one it's not bad though I just as it
is quite often in chests also matter of
taste and what kind of plan you prefer
black now decided short nor decided to
play the move c6 y c6
not c5 that was prevented but c6 y c6
isn't this passive hmm it looks passive
but it is in a way necessary let's have
a look what black wants to do is he
wants to develop his Knight at some
point the problem is solved then 97 is
just blundering this pawn and Knight a 6
an alternative way to put it out yeah
it's also not great because again we are
blundering the pawn so black has a
problem with the development of the
night you really can only develop it
once the d5 pawn is securely protected
and this means ok you have to play c6
it's not that great at the moment the
bishop looks at this pawn but it's not
there forever as we will see and it
prepares the complete development which
is really needed bishop f1 now is played
by es cos yeah this is a little
improvement move it puts the bishop on a
secure square it maybe prepares to
fianchetto which does make some sense if
the bishop is on g2 it would actually
increase the
on the d5 pawn so a quite useful move it
is a bit slow down black no plate nine
to eight a six yeah this is maybe a move
that needs some explanations what
exactly is the knight doing there it in
fact has a very good plan and idea what
black wants to do he wants to put the
night on e 6 e six is a very good square
for the knight here and we will see it
will appear there and in short order and
probably the benefits of this Knight
placement can be best explained
explained when we when we get them
instead Knight d7 was also possible this
one in order to play Knight f8 + 96 ya
can easily lead to the same thing so 97
or 96 this was chosen by by Nigel short
roopd - an interesting planner white
prepares a possible doubling on the D
file to fight against the c5 break what
I don't like about what approach here is
that is this a prophylactic approach and
it makes sure that well those breaks
cannot be easily played but he does not
really follow up with the pawn break on
his own
I really prefer to get this in at some
point to open up the position against
the Queen and maybe also get some bishop
going to see for once the d5 pawn is
traded so as mentioned I would have
preferred to play for the e4 break in
this position 97 and now I played the
move a form mm-hmm okay he wants to play
a4 a5 trying to fight the structure on
the Queen side 96 this was the plan and
a5 so wide after all decided to do
something active he simply couldn't
stand to just play em
a purely yeah preventional game where d5
should be prevented all the time after a
five what is flex movement it is hanging
on v6 so not much else
he went b5 it looks ugly right b5 what
an ugly move you don't really want this
kind of situation to happen but the
absolutely all important point is that
black still has the possibility for a
break with c5 this structure is only a
problem with this bishop on b7 when
black in some form is hindered from
playing c5 he wants to open up the
position for his bishops the bishops on
b7 and on f6 and at the moment this is
not yet critical less Black has still
this c5 at the end mind right now played
the move Queen a - retreating the Queen
from b3 and possibly preparing before
this is in fact something that black
must be very alert about white
absolutely shouldn't be allowed to play
the move before it's before is happening
it will be difficult for black to play
c-65 and this means that a very
important pawn break is taken away from
blacks arsenal of ideas so something to
be a to be very cautious about black now
played a6
white by the way could have played a6
himself but after Bishop c8 this is not
a huge problem this Bishop can relocate
later and in fact sometimes a6 might
even become a weakness you know it can
only be sensibly protected by the rook
at the moment well maybe at some point
black can even a ticket with a knight or
queen on B 6 and then the a6 pawn is
weak so I think we need to was was ok
it's nothing brilliant but it was ok
yeah now black played a6 to secure the
b5
this is a necessary move to make sure
that c5 is really possible yeah and now
we come to a to a very critical position
and in fact the critical position on one
critical position of this game right now
played the move rook to c1 yeah looking
at this pawn and maybe he thought that
long term he is able to yeah maybe get a
knight to c5 or prepare B form and then
yeah so somehow an IT to c1 viiia this
looks weird overnight that's a a - 2 c1
2 B 3 this kind of ideas looking at the
c5 square however the move rook c1 is
neglecting one very important detail
what you should have done is to play
rook 81 after which at least um right
retains an okay position after rook 81
black will play c5 and after the capture
on c5 which is pretty much necessary he
can just take on c3 with them with a
very decent position yeah one one
possible follow up is some just pawn
takes and Knight takes and here we see
that black in fact has the better
structure d5 at the movement is very
securely protected by the by the bishop
that's one of those cases where bad
bishops protect good pawns while black
is aiming for quick Knight e4 rook c8
putting pressure on the weak c3 square
screen c3 pawn and this is in fact the
more important weakness in this position
here black is somewhat more comfortable
nothing
decisive he won't win quickly but it's a
it's a nice position white or ever
played the move rook c1 and it seems
that he didn't really sense the danger
that was
was in this position now we come to the
the moment of the game that pretty much
it's the reason why the video has the
title that it has you want to use pawn
breaks to free your pieces and here
black has an excellent pawn break
available like not plate the move c5
this in itself is probably not very
surprising but it is great because it
forces white basically to take on c5
what else is there white cannot allow
black to take on deformed in some
scenarios autoplay c4 and before yeah
this would also be yeah quite a quite a
big problem for white it would look as
his rooks would look simply ridiculous
so why took and now the the decisive
point is coming black now is playing d4
yeah this is the the great point of the
whole thing this bishop all of a Sun is
becoming a monster piece and of course
this Bishop as well so black
ultimately has reached his goal the goal
that was already set a couple of moves
ago when we look back to the start of it
like around here black was suffering
from this passive bishop and this
passive bishop and with the the palm
break here he has managed to free go
with both of his pieces both bishops now
play an excellent role have a look again
f6 is activated b7 is activated and it's
all of course backed up by concrete
calculation what should why dunno why it
only has one with Knight takes d4 if he
takes with the pawn it is very simple
like is just taking on a3 and after G
takes Bishop g5 is winning the exchange
but not just the exchange the whole
position is really a rack for
I also note that there is always night
coming here or taking on d4 it's just
it's just terrible wide losses material
and has a bad position so he takes d4 is
not playable at all he has to take with
the knight
yeah how does black break through now it
is a technical thing already
Black Knight took with the bishop he
takes Knight takes yeah so one of the
great bishops
has been traded but it's not about
abstract things like a good piece a bad
piece anymore only because now we are
talking about tactics black now has
simply a huge attack based on its bishop
and this Knight yeah how should white
defend now the big problem is that there
are concrete threats already if you make
a slowish move that to be honest doesn't
make much sense something like that
there is just not a 3m this is the big
threat
why does playing the relatively best
defense I think with King to h1 getting
out of this let's check on f3 yeah and
now after this the the part of the game
where is about strategy here we at the
point of concrete calculation if you
want you can treat this position also as
a puzzle and try to find the best
attacking continuation for black what
short now is playing from this point is
it's the perfect attacking game I mean C
5 T 4 already is the start of it but the
the upcoming sequence is really
excellent yeah black to play and to get
a decisive attack what is the way what's
the way to go short played the excellent
move Knight f3 now yeah you can go to f3
anyway even without a check
yeah this is just this is just wrong the
rukon D - hangs and what kind of defense
should I try now yeah
white captured on d8 it seems that the
relatively toughest defense is the very
unnatural looking new through D - C -
after which black has a fantastic attack
but it's not totally easy in fact black
has a number of promising options based
on the fact that white so cannot really
take the night ever yeah that's still a
super dangerous attack it looks like
Queen f6 for example protects the knight
wrote technically the best move it seems
and this is a thing backed by the
computer here is roopd 2 which gives
blacks black a fantastic attack
something like the capture and before
does not look terrible at first for
white but a simple continuation like
this seems to be M yeah simply too
dangerous what black is trying to do
he's just trying to take here on
everyone
then Queen g5 with a but not that far
the main threat on g2 and then Luke T -
yeah it's maybe a little bit difficult
to understand what I'm saying yeah I
just should pull out a move here let's
say rook t1 then black goes Queen g5 and
he now threatens to take on f1 and made
on g2 it does not look that dangerous at
first but it is really really a problem
something like Queen a1 for example
black will take who takes Queen takes
Queen takes f1 and then ultimately Queen
d2 and we see that white has huge
problems the night has lost its
protection from the b2 pawn and really
has no no good square to go after any
Knight move we will just take here and
grab grab the whole Queen side with the
total win yeah blacks attack is
tremendous rook DC - would have been a
bit tougher
not clear short really well played rook
t2 which seems to be the strongest from
an engine perspective however other
moves would have been very very
dangerous as well we shouldn't discard
stuff like Queen f6 after which white
sir cannot take and black is intending
to yeah
get more pieces near the near the king
and the Queen especially so many many
dangerous attacking possibilities yeah
it is difficult to defend this position
definitely well ash Cass took on d8 and
black recaptured yeah again we can look
at this position can why take the knight
let's check it briefly takes check yeah
King g1 queen g5 is an immediate loss
and after this black at least can win
the exchange with a winning attack to
boot so you cannot take the knight yeah
white stride this is not that why try to
return one pawn the idea is that after
the capture 92 he wanted to gain this
tempo on the bishop however it is in
vain blacks attack is far too strong if
you want a tactical incarnation exercise
again you can try to go from here like
to continue the tech what is the
strongest attacking continuation should
be noted that both f3 and c6 is attacked
yeah blacks best move and played by
short is the very powerful move Queen to
h4 that's very very strong yeah it
attacks h2 with a mating threat and
really leaves white very little choice
what is so he is supposed to do here if
he plays a move like h3 as more than one
good move now but we can
think about that one for example and
something like rook c6 rookie one white
will not survive we can actually take on
f1 I'm sorry we can just take you over
look dead so it is it is a decisive
attack
what did why - he actually took on f3
yeah and now we just play Queen takes
the big point is that now we attack f1
and f3 white try to defend with Knight
f4 yeah what else is there yeah I could
have tried to take on c6 after that let
me think about it briefly yeah both rook
g1 and yeah this is this is even winning
something like that what only answer has
a check and there's also Queen f1 friend
so there is no defense here 93 for
example we cannot win like that the
other attack is this is decisive what
what right here was Knight f4 and now
after Bishop takes a three Bishop g2
black head the decisive means rook D -
yeah what a what a big attack
threatening on g2 yeah white now covered
with rook g1 there was also rook c8 as
something to check but after this there
is really no defense after Queen g1
there is rook t1 and black wins so very
very nice yeah he tried to what exactly
look g1 y and now comes the point
I mean likes position is great but how
do you win
isn't that like just about defending no
black has a nice point to it he now
played to move Bishop to g4
and this is very strong a very
simple-looking move it just threatens to
take the night and white has no way to
defend it yeah it's really nice
the night is saying if it moves there's
Bishop g2 where they're made to come or
alternatively yeah yup g2 is really the
quickest if we consider we can look at
this this is also made yeah tons of
mates white resigned him what to take
from this game we always should try to
activate pieces that are not positioned
properly but that have some inherent
energy to them like those bishops like
always wanted to activate the bishops
and he tried his best to place his
pieces in a way that it was possible to
play c5 at some point this was what
black was trying to do all the time and
in the game when White was a bit
careless this was playable and and play
to full effect c5 takes d4 a typical
breakthrough this is the kind of
breakthrough breakthrough should always
consider those that activate all your
pieces note that the bishops get active
and as a consequence here also the
knight connective so all pieces all of a
sudden got into the attack an excellent
game here by short who managed to win
really a huge number of games in the
tactic of a variation of the Queens
gambit with a direct attack that's it's
quite amazing it's a very yeah it has
some reputation of being a quiet opening
but he managed to attack that often it's
it's really amazing yeah I hope you
enjoyed this game showing the inherent
dynamics that are yeah sometimes hidden
in positions and that very often can be
can be unleashed by those pawn breaks I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching